[Musique]
ce mardi 21 novembre le Conseil
départemental a réuni l'ensemble des
acteurs du tourisme EPCI oti parc
national ou encore ONF pour évoquer son
futur schéma directeur d'aménagement et
de développement touristique des espaces
naturels départementaux un document qui
sera publié dans un an et dont
l'élaboration sera partenariale
aujourd'hui l'objectif de ce schéma
directeur c'est bien évidemment d'ouvrir
nos espaces remarquable au public donc
d'accueillir nos visiteurs dans des
conditions qualitatives et en
réussissant à maintenir la préservation
de notre biodiversité à travers la
régulation des flux de visiteurs sur nos
espaces alors la mission a été confiée
au cabinet Voltaire donc qui va
travailler sur une phase diagnostique et
donc il va faire l'état des lieux avec
tous nos partenaires sur bah nos espaces
remarquables donc cette mission va durer
un an pour pouvoir mettre en en place en
tout cas une vision
stratégique globale euh de de gestion de
ces espaces remarqua confié à un
groupement de bureaux d'études cette
mission débutera avec une phase de
diagnostic durant 3 mois avec pour
objectif de proposer une stratégie
d'intervention sur les espaces naturels
départementaux sur les 10 à 15
prochaines années les
[Musique]
pression